so i've got a whole pizza here and let's
say that i were to cut it into two equal
pieces let me cut it right over here
into two
equal pieces and let's say that i ate
one of those two equal pieces
so let's say i ate all of this right
over here what fraction of the pizza
have i eaten
well i took the whole and i divided it
into two equal i divided into two equal
pieces and then i ate one of those
pieces let me and then i ate
and then i ate one of those pieces so i
ate one half of the pizza
now let's imagine that instead of
dividing instead of cutting that that
pizza into only two equal pieces
let's imagine instead that i decided to
cut it into four equal pieces so let's
draw that
so four equal pieces
so
cut it i could cut it once this way
and then i could cut it once this way
and so here i have four equal pieces
four equal pieces but let's say that i
want to eat the same amount of pizza how
many of these four equal pieces would i
have to eat i encourage you to pause the
video and think about that
well
i would eat this piece you could imagine
me eating this piece and this piece
right over here i've eaten the same
amount of the pizza i just each of these
pieces you could imagine got cut into
two pieces when i cut the whole pizza
this way and so now i have to eat two
slices of the four as opposed to one
slice of the two so i just ate
two out of the four slices
so even though
these i'm using different numbers here
here i'm using a one half and here or
one in the numerator a two in the
denominator here i'm using a two in the
numerator and a four in the denominator
these two fractions represent the same
quantity i ate the same amount of pizza
if i eat two fourths of a pizza if i eat
two out of four equal pieces that's the
same fraction of the pizza as if i eat
one out of two equal pieces so we would
say that these two things are equivalent
fractions
now let's do another one like this
instead of just dividing into four equal
pieces let's let's divide it into eight
equal pieces
eight equal pieces
so now
we could
we could cut
once like this so now we have two equal
pieces
cut once like
this now we have four equal pieces and
then divide each of those four pieces
into two pieces so cut those in so here
we have so let's see
i want to make them equal pieces those
don't look as equal as i would like
so
that looks more equal and then
that looks
reasonably equal
so now how many equal pieces do i have i
have eight equal pieces
i have eight equal pieces but let's say
i wanted to eat the same fraction of the
pizza so i could eat all of these pieces
right over here well how many of those
eight equal pieces have i eaten well
i've eaten one two three four of those
eight equal pieces and so once again
this fraction four of eight or four
eighths is equivalent to two-fourths
which is equivalent to one half
and you might see a little bit of a
pattern here going from this scenario to
this scenario i got twice as many i got
twice as many equal slices because i had
twice as many equal slices i needed to
eat 2 times the number of slices
so i multiplied the denominator by 2
and i multiplied the numerator by 2. if
i multiply the numerator and the
denominator by the same number then i'm
not changing what that fraction
represents and you see that over here
going from four slices to eight slices i
cut every slice i turned every slice
into two more slices
so i had twice as many slices and then
if i want to eat the same amount i have
to eat twice as many twice as
twice as many pieces so all of these
one-half two-fourths four-eighths and i
could keep going i could do
eight sixteens i could do sixteen 30
seconds all of these would be equivalent
fractions